[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
open that Golden Gate good evening I'm
Stuart brand in the long now foundation
you've been getting a bit of a pitch on
the screen here I should tell you that
you should I should tell you the state
of the pitch you've been seeing about
this long now bar at Fort Mason that
we're raising money for with five
hundred thousand the complete bar will
be happening we've raised one hundred
thousand so far it's moving as soon as
we get half the way there two hundred
fifty thousand we will start
construction could happen by the end of
the year now where else could you get
tax where else could you get a tax
credit for helping build a bar last year
when I was here I say I was sort of
pitching membership and I said that
there's special things that members get
to do and I said there's a secret
project coming along we didn't know if I
was going to happen members would know
about it first and ideally participate
and I can say this year that that
project came to pass is called revive
and restore we're setting in motion
bringing back extinct species starting
with a passenger pigeon and moving on to
others we're working with National
Geographic and with the TED conferences
there will be a TEDx extinction C in
March and we'll try to get a special
admittance there for long now members
and how many long Nam members are here
by the way tonight yeah so you'll recall
that after the show we get all the
members up here on the stage for a group
of photographs there was one that was
showing during the pitch there this
event this is one of those deals where
the audience is half the show and so
it's sort of real-time crowdsourcing
it's helpful if you say things
as the show goes along and if you want
to have long now thoughts I heard from
Rick that the oldest film tonight will
be probably about 80 years old going
back to 1932 so long now is certain
period of time in the past or in period
of time in the future you can think
about how the smartphone videos that
you're shooting now
will look 80 years from now and what
kind of plane E&C will be in there now
on the spirit of crowd participation I
want you to help me with something which
is every year I ask Rick how his last
name is pronounced and every year he
tells me and then I forget so you can
help all of us get it right it's
pronounced Rick Prelinger pay linger
pray linger okay let's hear it Rick
Prelinger
pay linger and now welcome Rick
[Applause]
thank you thank you let's ignore the
cult of personality and move forward
from that I'm welcome to lost landscapes
number seven the Nutcracker for the 21st
century a few very important things to
get out of the way there's some thank
yous the San Francisco History Center
San Francisco Public Library has made
some really yes support our public
history institutions they've made some
really amazing and an unseen material
available to us for this show tonight so
shot out to them also like to mention a
new project which i think is going to
make a big difference over the next few
years
it's called memories to light Asian
American home movies this is a project
that actually spun out of earlier lost
landscape shows and the wonderful home
movies from the G family whom you may
remember Cathy G is with us tonight they
are are starting a project to request
home movie footage from the
asian-american community and create an
interactive website and curate regional
national shows stories and so on so I
think that we're going to see a vast up
swelling of of unknown history
tremendously excited about that and um
I'd also like to give very very special
thanks to a group of friends and
volunteers who have the tremendously
unwieldy name of San Francisco
participatory archives group these are
26 people who since March have been
inspecting identifying documenting
repairing preparing archival film for
scanning much of it will be in this show
tonight and this show would not have
been possible without them so thank you
all so much
[Applause]
so what happens tonight we have a 75
minute film and then we're gonna have a
panel discussion with with three
distinguished panelists and myself and
try to get to a few ideas so during the
show of course I want to hear
identifications I want to hear questions
I want to hear you disputing your
neighbors incorrect ID in fact I might
even throw out a few mistakes myself if
you're a little quiet because nothing
gets an audience louder than correcting
a mistake but for the for the the brief
discussion after the show if you choose
to stay you'll be hearing from great
Brecon local historian geographer and
author of the wonderful book Imperial
San Francisco and Suzanne Fisher
distinguished public historian who's
just come out from the Henry Ford in
Dearborn Michigan to join the Oakland
Museum as curator of Oakland Museum of
California as curator of contemporary
history well worth listening to
so as Stewart said this is an
interactive program you are the
soundtrack most of it is silent this
theater is a cone it's intended to
channel your psychological and emotional
attention towards the glowing rectangle
but I'm going to ask you to go against
the architectural intentions which were
otherwise good and talk to one another
and it means you've really got to try to
project a little bit so please be vocal
that's that's part of the fun um in
order to help facilitate I'll be taking
a mic and pointing out some things and
we also have I'd like to introduce woody
Labonte come on earth woody take a
moment in the spotlight woody is a
co-founder of the Western neighborhoods
project and author of a number of books
including the spanking-new Ingleside
terraces which is
local history with a punch that's right
and I love doing this every year with
the long now foundation and little known
fact this mic is made of five
thousand-year-old bristlecones and
that's my last joke of the night rig
alright alright we're gonna stick to the
evidence have a swell time and we'll see
you afterwards
[Applause]
what was that
traditionally this program has begun
with an airplane landing at SFO in 1941
but this show for some reason seems to
be pretty water focused so we're gonna
enter San Francisco by ferry key system
ferry the top of the shed that the ferry
just came out of the pier reads east
shore Empire
what's that structure in the background
thank you
early forties first best I can do for
you is that the Embarcadero Freeway no
it's not that
Ferry Building is right did the cars go
on the ferry somebody wants to know yes
this is footage shot by the Spreckels
sugar company showing busy working San
Francisco waterfront in the 20s we're
going south around the city naturally
home movies from the mid-30s home movies
are really the backbone of every lost
landscapes and we found some great ones
this year what street is this anybody
know very good market
we don't know the date but we know the
time yeah I was gonna say 422 was that a
gas station that we saw on the right
there Rick I believe was there a gas
station there oh just street car
dispatching house somebody said
so this is a a process plate shot for a
feature film background in about 1932
and I've never seen detailed footage of
Market Street from this period it's kind
of a void in the archives and it's
really extremely detailed so Rick is
this like in a movie somebody would be
driving you'd see this out the rear
window movie exactly it's a background
process played how many tracks on market
a gentleman asked for
see they didn't want me to make any
jokes but you guys keep it up the
cowcatcher those are to catch to catch
people that are fortunate wayward
children well it's dangerous if you're
trying to catch the car in the inner
tracks you have a relatively slim safety
zone there's gonna be more about that
little later on
okay angle side and there's the see car
anybody can tell us about the see car
California Street and the number four
that's the Market Street Railway which
was a private company the white front
cars
where did the d-line go venison Union
like the 47
there were a lot of homeless people in
San Francisco in 1932 but I have a
feeling they weren't very welcome on
Market Street
I think they were yellow
there's Ladas fountain right and the
chronicle building on the left
Hearst building on the right somebody
says there's the examiner right corner
of third
yeah people are pointing out the little
stop-and-go traffic signals very small
yes they rotate news cameraman and a
couple of brief labor parades I don't
have a date
the ship fitters union this would have
been after the strike I think that was
after the yeah this is probably late 30s
early 40s I've not inspected the film
for a date yet any ideas where this is
up to no home movies out-of-focus this
is late 20s you notice the shape of the
signs with those lettering neon was
relatively new and a lot of signs were
actually made out of little incandescent
light bulbs
what's that building on the hill thank
you some you can if you look hard you
can see the Montgomery block the old
Hall of Justice just zoomed by we'll see
more of it Custom House Southern Pacific
building yeah which we know from vertigo
blinking and little feature outtake well
checked in on Foursquare
[Music]
this is a home movie shot approximately
1931 in the Chinatown Barbary Coast area
we've seen a few shots before but it's
been rescan so you can see a little more
than we we saw last time fur is murder
if anybody is interesting
so the Barbary Coast had been closed
down and these buildings are essentially
derelict and and they're for sale in in
1930 why I know some people know what
theater that is Hippodrome very good but
in a moment we're gonna see a new clip
and I think quite a rare clip of her
sells founded by Luke Purcell and Sam
King two African American X Bullman
porters Comstock Building yeah notice
there's a bond issue for relief that's
on the ballot so on here's a here's per
cells this is a clip I've never seen
before it's very clear it's very sturdy
five millimeter and here's a favorite
it's people from the future chasing me
[Applause]
if anybody knows what film that is I'd
love to know now we know what this is
right Bimbo's 365 there was the ball
table in 1931 to 1950 and Portsmouth
Square and our old Hall of Justice 1912
to about 62 pretty hard to demolish it
was built to last and from a late 40s
homemade travelogue
is this in the movie you're seeing this
sir
where are they Rick outtakes from the
official San Francisco Convention and
Visitor's Bureau film how did this not
get into the final film where is this
where is this looks like city lights
it's a little city lights Columbus
now it takes for a reason
what year was quite tower built
difference of opinion finished in 34 on
the left side
look at how many fairies they are that's
just an incredibly eloquent statement of
a city that moved on water it doesn't
look like green technology though
Treasure Island World's Fair what was
the name of that big tower there Tower
of the Sun thank you some of you may
remember this clip this is from the
lineup shot in 57 released 58
this is the end right this is where they
get the guy on the unfinished freeway oh
sorry
[Laughter]
[Applause]
who is
[Applause]
that was cheap Rick cheap it's all in
the eye of the spectator I this is his
footage that hasn't much been seen from
San Francisco History Center but it's
kind of amazing because they're working
right over the waterfront and it's as
interesting on the periphery as it is
the work that these these nerves of
steel guys are doing well good question
what stage of the bridge is this about
34 I take a guess I think yeah somebody
said there's no ocean it seems like
these films were actually made by the
California Industrial Safety Commission
I swear to God
maybe it was a we can do better film
this is before it's finished right
which bridge was finished first who
knows all right heads up everybody so
Rincon Hill the bridge is probably just
about finished but they haven't cleaned
up but we're gonna see something in just
a moment that I thought was quite
unusual this is I believe Harrison
Street um but we're gonna come back down
from it look the last Wow residents yeah
that in that area fourth one of the old
Rincon Hill houses I was amazed to find
that where there that house there was a
fight over said there's a plaque
somewhere on Rincon Hill that
memorializes the conflict
Elmas hills the city now presents a
complex traffic problem because most of
its long streetcar lines must funnel
into Market Street this is true because
there are no streets parallel to market
on the north side as the city grows the
Market Street bottleneck draws tighter
and tighter
unless relief is found this condition
will seriously hamper the city's growth
and progress Market Street as it looks
today from a balcony at fifth Street
this as you all know is just an average
crowd trying to find a way to get home
balcony the cable car turned on Powell
Street the cable car is a San Francisco
invention and our visitors never quit
talking about it will probably always
have at least one cable car route here
just as a tourist attraction we all ride
to work but how we have to work to ride
here's a rush-hour example people stand
and safety zones hoping the inspector
will find room for them up front but the
space is all taken and disappointed
patrons are turned away here's why too
many cars are on the outside tracks
owned by the Municipal Railway hitter
the inside tracks owned by Market Street
Railway are not used to capacity if
these two systems are consolidated the
traffic burden will be equally
distributed so that everybody can ride
one pair anywhere will do the trick
what about bike lanes the unequal burden
causes this inconvenient dangerous and
entirely unnecessary when Madame Chiang
kai-shek was here the traffic burden
everywhere was too great under three
systems three management's and three
fares will all agree this is a beautiful
scene but the discomfort and envy
are they're just the same we can correct
this situation with one management one
fare anywhere and free transfers
everywhere this serious bottleneck gets
Stockton and Market streets can be
broken instead of turning F cars back
here let's send them across Market
Street to the Southern Pacific people
giving a new crosstown service to the
marina North Beach and Chinatown let's
speed up this overloaded line let's give
the Mission District direct access to
north of Market sections no mother likes
this kind of a situation involving
schoolchildren we spend millions for
schoolroom education let's spend
something on traffic and safety what's
that building what are we doing for our
war workers these tired men coming off
shift need speedy service home for a
well-earned rest here seventy right
shipyards instead they keep right on
word company working as you do for a
place on an overcrowded bus or streetcar
and often payment of two fares before
they reach home these are not shoppers
waiting for a shinned meet these are war
plant workers waiting in line for a
chance to ride home they deserve that
chance and you deserve that chance think
of the thousands of hours we lose daily
by transportation delays think of the
ships and bombers that might have been
built with this lost time we can't
afford it we need those ships and
bombers Sparsit street cars now lie
unused in car barns and chops Deponia
all these can be put to work on idle
tracks based on market and mission
streets let's use them I think that's
the inner senses like 1451 management
and with one pair anywhere these idle
cars can carry twenty thousand more
people every day during the rush hours
alone it K like this and better new
noiseless speedy streamlined cars fast
modern motor coach
taking the places of streetcars wherever
possible only in this way can San
Francisco get rid of two of the four
tracks on Market Street you would like
that wouldn't just returns these are
hopes for the future they are more than
hosts they are necessities if the city
we all love is not to strangle from its
congestion and bottlenecks let's take
the necessary step
Tuesday April 20th let's consolidate the
existing systems without one cent of
cost to taxpayers the entire bill will
be paid from revenues now swollen
because there are so many newcomers here
and the three systems are mutinous is
the city that knows how ours and here's
how vote YES on Tuesday for better
service at no added cost internet let's
forget our pet peeves and our prejudices
ition let's think of the needs of our
city and our country let's do something
for San Francisco
are you listening San Francisco this is
the message of the Citizens Committee
for better streetcar service we're
voting YES for your future on Tuesday
did that measure pass
[Music]
over the hills and all along the way
we're building a dream for tomorrow
[Music]
we're building
a dream for tomorrow weddings where
trains that cross the hills and land go
through the Tom by night and day and
sunshine touches every hand in parks
where children play
over the hills and all along the way
we're building the dreams for tomorrow
we're building a dream for tomorrow
where there
a dream for tomorrow
we're building a dream for tomorrow
along the way in three counties Bart is
building a high speed rail rapid transit
system planned for your convenience
designed for your comfort and
deliberately aimed at giving you a safer
faster more economical ride than your
automobile fully aware as Lewis Mumford
says that a city exists not for the
constant passage of motorcars but for
the care and culture of men cities will
maintain their character to unscarred by
heavy concrete swaths of freeway
freeways that carry the extravagance of
one car one passenger mostly at a
standstill
instead Bart trains carrying thousands
of comfortably seated passengers will
glide quietly through the bay to under
the Ferry Building and into the Market
Street subway and when it's completed
you and the Bay Area will not only feel
better you'll both look better in the
polls Street Station you'll look
something like this along the way you
may stop at a magazine stand by commute
tickets from the automatic vending
machine enjoy the clean spacious
architect-designed station and then
you'll board a train carpeted
air-conditioned settle into an
extra-wide foam rubber seat
and all along the way we're building
[Music]
for tomorrow
everybody we're building
the dream for tomorrow
[Music]
our commuters get one of the most
exciting rides in the world and boy what
a view
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
there's that spice and coffee smell
again
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
one of the busiest intercity transit
lines in the world safely delivers
another train little passengers for the
busiest terminal in America
[Music]
so as part of the celebration for the
opening of the Golden Gate Bridge poke
Gulch made itself into a faux western
town I just read that there was a riot
and Polk Gulch during the bridge opening
there probably people know a lot more
about this than I do but this is footage
that I've not seen before from San
Francisco Public Library
they had this Fiesta theme for the
opening the Colgate bridge and all the
neighborhoods would dress like old
Cowboys and have little parades and
things they really worked out at though
and misspelled signs
[Applause]
that guy did not look like the Old West
though I that's a bohemian
I mean the the Old West you know was as
far away from then as like 1962 is from
today
a little bit of home movie what Beach is
that and footage that I've not
previously seen of the celebration
there's a few interesting things to note
here
oil drive
yeah we'll never forget it
it's before the clock got put in huh no
clock
who is the Doyle of Doyle Drive somebody
wants to know well is there more than
the first name you know we'll get back
to you I heard a banker from the banker
I think the original plan was actually
to charge pedestrians just to walk on
the bridge after it opened not just for
this first day I think they did for
quite a while they did how much was it a
dime okay now you can walk on it for
free cars were 50 Cent's what's it now
six dollars it then I think it went up
to 65 didn't it but that's a lot of
money you got to multiply by like 12 or
18 Fort Point people are still in
costume
so somebody said the auto toll started
out at 25 cents and they still have the
sign where is it in the repair yard
fascinating
apparently they couldn't make up their
mind this is what I find interesting
they're serving beer on the bridge
you know they complain that the ferries
are losing money what kind of ship is
that I think yeah look at this
say aircraft carriers oh cool
that's the Saratoga somebody says man
they got a lot of planes on those things
that that must be they must be moving
the planes from one place to another
because
Great White Fleet that was earlier
wasn't it it is white
this is one measure if the the toll was
fairly expensive for those times and the
traffic was fairly low the first few
years or perhaps this is early Sunday
morning
yes
just a little bit of tourism from about
1959 if I'm not mistaken maybe a bit
later
yes I like that
so closed in 62 as a prison 63 thank you
all right so in October 8 1936 the
Ohioan ran aground and some people say
this is the most photographed shipwreck
but there's not a lot of really good
movie footage of it but this was great
it's from the Public Library big crowds
came to watch the salvage and then it
caught fire in March 1937 and it broke
into pieces in in December
there it is on the right Oh thousands a
wave motor machine to try to harness the
energy of the waves we're gonna see that
again pretty soon that's an early idea I
mean we think of it as a modern one but
not really so that was actually a
different ship the Lyman's Stuart and
the Frank H H buck were two sister ships
that essentially crashed in the same
place a little farther east of the
Ohioan where this is this would be just
north of where the Sutro Baths were
we're very maritime and water focus
today so this is a feature outtake shot
at Bethlehem Steel Company and the
shipyards at Pier 70 during World War
Two and one of the things that we don't
do much of anymore in San Francisco but
just the scale of this job and the
resources that needed to be mobilized to
build these ships it's this footage
gives you a really really good idea um
what did Bethlehem Steel builds somebody
probably knows more about this than I do
steel ships
Kizer built Liberty ships in Richmond
and other other cities and Marin - in
Sausalito Marin City
it's called Marin [ __ ] that was a yeah
that was a peck doll
oh they fabricated the tube sections
here
this is pr70 what's the cross street
20th east of 3rd
so again this was shot as the backdrop
for some kind of drama so people would
be talking or walking in front of this
judging from the rest of the film in
this collection I'd say 43 to 44 it
seems to be for some picture and I'm not
even sure what the name is that was
released by Columbia in 1944 mostly the
shipyard stuff shot in in in LA but
there's a little bit that's is this
public domain no it's actually
copyrighted as an unpublished work but
Internet Archive loans it puts it up
online for unrestricted free use and HD
it's from a 35 nitrate negative okay can
anybody guess who this is and where we
are Candlestick Park is correct
these are Giants fans in about 19 Wow
early 60s mid 60s the orange tie
this is before the merchandising sort of
really took off you know it's not like
everybody's got a giant sweatshirt or
jacket on you know they were in their
regular clothes
you notice that gentleman carrying a
blanket there's another blanket if you
remember candlestick funny yet sunny out
you never know Rick you never know
so those sideburns make records the
Fillmore Street counterbalance Thank You
Ric Lao sure of the Market Street
Railway this is rare color footage from
what was it about 1939 we decided so a
counterbalance means that one going up
has to have another one going down yeah
the car going down pulls the car going
up the other direction
and when was this line pulled up this is
film war
so um this is a home movie collection
that we found this year it's the he
wrote a family doctor Karl and his
spouse ooh table doctor Hirota went to
UC School of Dentistry they were married
in 1935 they were both incarcerated at
the Topaz camp in Utah in 1941
afterwards they were released and
permitted to move to Salt Lake City and
then after the war allowed to return in
San Francisco dr. Hirata was in the
442nd the most decorated army regiment
captain in the US Army Dental Corps in
his office was at the corner of Sutter
and Buchanan at 1797 solder and although
I don't show it here because it takes
place in LA he was very active in the
japanese-american Citizens League which
was located right around the corner at
1759 - 61 Sutter so this is a small bit
of a large collection of film that I
pulled because it showed the the streets
and the landscapes of Japan town and the
Western Addition
so it's a fire
I haven't inspected the film and
correlated this with an edge code my
guess is that this is probably I think
it's immediate post-war but it could be
pre-war in Japanese tea garden
and off to Japan and the maths and ship
so we're looking forward to seeing what
Center for Asian American media's
project can discover they are family
members still in the Bay Area
so in mid-december 1938 Chinese
Americans especially on the west coast
became concerned about the trade in
scrap iron between the u.s. and Japan
especially after the rape of Nanking and
starting in in mid-december 1938 there
were protests organized on the the
Embarcadero by the United Chinese
societies which were joined by
longshoremen and in in mid-december 38
5,000 maybe more Chinese Americans
picketed the piers and tried to organize
a boycott but the employers the ship
owners and the waterfront employers were
not ready to play ball and the the scrap
iron trade continued for the while but
the the International Longshoremen's and
we're husband's Union organized a
boycott and the reason I'm leading up to
this is we found a little bit of
extremely unusual home movie footage
showing one of these picket lines in in
late 1938 north of market outside pier
25 so we're going to see that fragment
in just a moment
can't quite tell who these people are
this is quite well documented this is
the the era of vertigo
that is indeed that's a fighter
don't know I believe this is the 1962
blizzard
and this is a home movie shot by some
German tourists in San Francisco con a
bar that's right where we are right
where we are and I just you know since
it looks kind of breathtaking on the big
screen I thought we'd take a tour
through the neighborhoods we're going up
the hill what year was this I did before
the Market Street extension I think it's
about 59 so yeah we're doing the Corbett
up the hill here a lot of it looks much
the same which tells you something I
know where we are now would ya
Portola yeah hey West Portal school
that's when they had to wings there's
some graduates from West Portal school
here in Forest Hill that's the giant
staircase up Jayco and Forest Hill
Station Laguna Honda oh how did we get
out here okay sorry laughs yeah we know
what that is
Sutro Heights yes he's getting a little
bit breathless are we gonna see a giant
camera that's the old iron pier that
used to go out it was a suck seawater
into a pumping station to shoot it
downtown
yes Playland in the background stay
tuned a merry way parking lot just
briefly hey the gas station Oh Rick I've
been looking for pictures of that gas
station forever that's all we got okay
here's a little heartwarming scenic
is this a car commercial what is this
it's just an outtake from some detective
TV show it's one division of San
Francisco and here's another one what
street
filbert is a guess
is this San Francisco beat outtakes it
might well be
this is about 1937 ish from the San
Francisco Public Library Golden Gate
Park what are they playing
very late 20s very early 30s this is a
new scan of some hipsters of the period
looking for kicks in Sutra Heights park
and then
I want to know what's inside those
bushes that's the gate of Point Lobos
Road and the Lions you're gonna see here
are still up there
they're bison
I count 16 17 18 I think there's 20
those the gate is open by the way
so yeah this is during Prohibition and
one of the things that as in
contemporary youtubes there's a big
thing about people shooting
transgressive behavior and there are so
many home movies of people drinking up
and the depression and they're filming
their food which is another common thing
people do today yeah all right
the woman on the left is totally wasted
see
holiday decorations where are we
Daly City that doesn't sound unclear
um so we're seeing these movies through
the courtesy of Linda Pelt's who as it
turns out grew up one block from where
we live this is 16th Avenue in the
Richmond District pre-world War two
it's not as quiet out in the avenues as
they say this is um so the here is a I
think this is called warrior this is a
homemade civil defense emergency card
that was going that was going to prevent
to help help remediate disasters Balboa
to Cabrillo 16th to 17th Avenue and so
it's like Newark today right it's just
like nur today but they did a nice job
so later they moved to another
neighborhood woody what do you think
looks like the Parkside to me that's a
guess like in the Sunset District is
that the reservoir where we going them
but check out the little patches of
grass of lawn
yeah that looks like it's in the 20s and
near the reservoirs my guess
all right the early theater
Irving theater do we know where that was
14th to 15th I believe yeah your honor
Venus Street Wow what's going on this is
a parade and we're gonna see Boy Scouts
not in who else if it just has one
policeman clearing the way it's a small
parade you know they used to have these
giant sort of parades for festival at
st. Ann's but they look like they're
going the wrong direction now
this is um in the sunset and if you
notice the dunes are across the street
we'll see a little more of them but they
haven't built out the Sunset District
yet this is a somewhat shorter version
of a clip I've shown but it's so amazing
palm trees - we got palm trees yeah
they're all dressed up for Easter right
this is a subdivision built by that
company what's the name
what do you think the French thing which
oh the Russo it's the Russo yeah Oliver
Russo so they have little storybook
looking stucco homes that look like
little French chateaus and castles and
very neat so this this is AB around
Sunset Boulevard maybe that's maybe what
the sand dunes were yeah I think it's in
the first okay yeah so this was a film
made about so called Francisco
the golden samsa skull I know I live
there on the tower we go
did you but I like it yeah we dig it to
moles on a towel oh I can see everything
what's in a while ice pack I'd be the
shoes they faint they the toughest but
not the bosses nothing to do we I had
something like that on my corner
I'd shimmy shimmy Coco Co to the mo you
can always tell
Plan B ace on every corner
I'll look too hard fellas they got
guards you got a thousand fellas the key
in this tough scene it's the bosses
because aspiring from some honor at
night
you can always tell that's the lonely
ones bet you some parts of mission could
always tail 1,080 corner hair was a
crime they'd be right on Decker with
chestnut
got old man legato main mic is on this
thing at first sight up fellows
didn't cause me anything bad thing has
been a quick getaway time to us at work
so I'm from the Brusco collection
contributed by Jesse meek as Santa Claus
visits the Emporium and I don't have an
exact date you all might have to guess
thank you thank you you're thinking on
your feet
I think it's 60s early to mid 60s
what's with the big tiger though anybody
know
right markets torn up for Bart and in a
minute you're gonna see some truly epic
jammed up traffic this is when they had
rides up at the top
remember the rides and the roof for the
kids where would you go for chicken soup
after kress yeah okay
so weird ray Wilson High School out on
man Sal is now closed I think was at 66
no yeah now Phillip its Ella Burton
academic high school but this is a like
I'm gonna say a pet parade yeah we used
to have like homecoming things where we
get the cars all sort of tricked out
like this
and I just feature I'll take that's too
gorgeous for words look and see if you
can see any empty lots with dunes looks
like there's sand in a lot of the
gardens that hasn't been covered we're
Sunset Boulevard planting yet yeah
poling west early fifties looks like
there's still a few empty spaces in the
landscape not yet but it will be
Internet Archive
we turn up the sound distant tiny bit
this is my demand brought back from last
year amateur professional amateur film
and cinema scope San Francisco within
its 45 square miles is contained one of
the most colorful and romantic cities in
the world approaching from the south the
traveller views with sudden excitement
the city thrusting its white towers into
the blue California sky
but it is from the east that the city
reveals its famous profile framed by the
silver towers of the Bay Bridge
[Music]
credited with having stopped the
onslaught of the 1906 fire Venice Avenue
still remains one of San Francisco's
broadest thoroughfares
fornia palace of the Legion of Honor one
of San Francisco's finest museums is an
exact replica of the Legion of Honor in
Paris
[Music]
the one ski resort of the 90s is now a
modern restaurant fronting the Pacific
Ocean and overlooking seals rocks
a ride on the newly installed sky tram
should be included in the tourist
itinerary
[Music]
this was one of the slowest attractions
in San Francisco
a hundred feet or something right
it took an interminable amount of time
[Music]
just below the cliff house is a
year-round amusement park
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
leaving the recreational areas the part
of the ocean we turn eastward for the
heart of the city
in the center of the city rise San
Francisco's famous Twin Peaks
[Music]
reached by a spiraling road the summit
commands a spectacular view of the
encircling city
[Music]
Market Street the main artery over to
the downtown area stretches like a broad
ribbon from Twin Peaks to the Ferry
Building
[Music]
busy intersection of Powell and Market
streets in downtown San Francisco is
located one of the terminals of the
Powell Street cable car line to reverse
their direction the cable cars are
pushed on to the unique turntable and
swung around manually by the motorman of
the conductor much to the delight of the
riders and spectators
there is no end to the interesting
places one may visit in San Francisco
the Ferry Building the churches and
colleges or the tourists may prefer a
leisurely drive along the many scenic
boulevards
[Music]
for the true adventurer there is that
final thrill ride down the world's most
crooked streets - room eight hairpin
turns in a single block
[Applause]
professional driver on a closed course
[Applause]
[Applause]
San Francisco the cosmopolitan city
queen of the Pacific
the city by the Golden Gate
[Music]
truly the city of many wonders
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
and join us for our brief discussion if
you'd like let's hear for the archives
group
[Applause]
thank you this is the panel of many
wonders it is indeed
so Museum question yes old images like
this do and mean these kind of images
have many meanings and I think all of
you may have taken different different
stories and different meanings from the
images that you've seen tonight this is
not one story that we're giving to you
but something that history is something
that people create along with along with
the artifacts
it's participatory
year after year Rick you've been going
through this stuff and we're probably
seeing just a fraction of what you went
through
editing just for this particular night
what adds up as you do more and more of
that do you just glaze over to something
else happen it is difficult to look at a
lot of things fast forward this year I
looked at about 2,400 new items with you
know the one thing I took away and I
really started to realize this last year
when you see things like the scrap metal
demonstration in 1937 or percise
dancehall you realize that probably
almost everything was photographed you
just have to find it almost every
episode in the history of our city
almost every place there is probably
home movie or other footage if you look
hard enough
now what's your sense of the stuff
that's being shot now by everybody how
does that how's that gonna collect and
play in the future do we know well most
of it will disappear because it's not in
any kind of it's in a format that's you
know the default condition of analog
media like film is to survive and the
default condition of digital media is
not to survive and if we're shooting a
billion videos a week in the world right
now we're not going to have most of them
so it'll take a while for it to shake
out but we will know what we have by
what we've lost in other words this sort
of subtraction is growth in a way
yeah funny thing I'm about 74 almost and
you know I recognized Frederick Rosco in
his bookstore that's right next to City
Lights Grand Avenue there and the stuff
fell into this the things I sort of
recognized that cars the clothes I
recognized for my life and the stuff
that was before that and it all look the
same
and so this kind of long now thing
happened of punching through the the
world that didn't exist because I always
thought didn't exist because you know I
didn't wasn't around to notice it and
boys that pop through that you know with
the barrier of one's birth and ones
coming of age or my case coming to
California at a certain time that's kind
of a long now a thing to happen so what
do you guys make of that kind of
durational recognition I think there's a
really interesting story that we that we
saw in this film the the Pope Gulch
commemoration of a past that they
vaguely remembered and they idealized in
a certain way and that flowed together
in a certain way so that you had people
dressed as Cowboys driving Oldsmobiles
from the 1890s because it was all sort
of it was all in the past it was all
pre-earthquake West something you know
so there's this tendency to for the
details to disappear and to merge
together and I think that one of the
that some of the work that we can do is
to is to make sure that we understand
each of those moments as as part of a as
part of a continuum that keeps going I
found myself wanting to ask gray whether
the Selective appropriation of Western
history and the poke Gulch Fiesta was
anything like we might be doing now as
we watch this
in other words their week it is this is
the San Francisco that we construct as
we watch this footage is it a fantasy or
is it is it more authentic than it might
have been before we saw these clips was
the you mean the poke Gulch yeah are we
doing the same thing or we constructing
a selective portrait of San Francisco
from our where we stand
yeah I think everybody does I mean know
every city does San Francisco is kind of
laundered its reputation because it's so
beautiful and you know it's a lot easier
to be critical of say Los Angeles and do
noir movies in Los Angeles but you know
we're that poll what the pol Gulch one
reminded me of was that there was a very
similar thing just a few years later on
Treasure Island and so it was sort of
getting ready for that and of course
that was a very whitewashed history and
the uglier aspects of San Francisco
really got scrubbed out
yeah I mean but I think because San
Francisco capitalizes on the Wild West
that legend of the gold rush the
Comstock sort of gets edited out of it
and people tend to forget how really
ugly that was in so many ways
particularly in the way that it
destroyed the environment so completely
and the kind of ugliness of racism for
example so as I say every city I think
does it but one of the things I really
appreciated about I think this was the
best so far of all the Lost landscapes
and what I really appreciated about this
is that it's really the northeast
quadrant of San Francisco that is so
photogenic and gets you know gets undue
coverage they di keep sort of swinging
around to the towers and my god we used
to have a beautiful skyline especially
when you came across the the Bay Bridge
it was so beautiful and it was so
reflective you know I mean the thing
about the the old towers is because they
were largely stucco and concrete they
reflected light and so the city had that
beautiful mediterranean quality which
when you put up glass skyscrapers which
absorb light I mean it just doesn't have
the same thing and then they don't have
the grace of Tim pflueger's buildings
Tim also built this wonderful theater
here - let's hear it for Tim but but
what I really liked about this one is
that you go out into the neighborhood so
much more and and I'm just really
lusting to see some some home movies in
the portal portal of district and the
Bayview Hunters Point and Ocean View
great I'm impressed that some of the
things that really last are basically
geological so that shot where you're
coming by probably Sutro Baths and then
there's the cliff house and then you
turn that corner and Ocean Beach opens
out that phenomenon is exactly the same
as it was then the buildings have
changed a little bit but the ocean is
there Seal Rocks is there - seals and
the beach is a big event with or without
that long pier geology really laughs and
the bridges especially the Golden Gate
Bridge kind of celebrates the geology of
what's going on both sides of it well I
was you know I think the problem with
the Golden Gate bridges is so damn
beautiful but I sort of disagree with
you on that I think that the problem
with the Golden Gate is that it with the
bridge is that it's sort of stolen the
attention from what a remarkable feature
the Golden Gate itself really is I mean
it is so beautiful and I remember the
first time I walked across it as a
teenager and I thought my god this
should be a national park and that was
about 1964 I saw it I never imagined it
would become a national park but yeah
this is a remarkable physical feature
and you can see that you know if cars go
away and we all have antigrav the robot
control their cars or something like
that that the bridge will stay there
because people are going to want to walk
on it just as we saw in the film
you know why he's got any questions
another thing that really surprised me
in those post-war movies is it looks
like you were seeing the kind of smog I
remember in the Bay Area before we got
the what was the air quality Act Clean
Air Act yeah I mean I don't think that
was fog I think you were because I
remember that there were times when over
in in Berkeley you could scarcely see
the Campanile II from the edge of campus
so some things do improve actually
questions what do you wish someone would
film now for somebody 30 years from now
gay pride yes I mean lots of people do
there's you know thousands and thousands
of minutes that are shot that question
is are they are they saved I guess I'd
like to see I'd like to see people think
about recording the kinds of things that
that happen in private life that they
don't think to photograph in other words
we socialize and we party and we go to
places that we think are beautiful but
there are aspects of private life that
we don't shoot and we don't record and
when I'm looking at home movies of
people traveling across country in the
30s 40s 50 60s when they actually go
into a restaurant when they go into a
bar when they go into a bar then into a
market then you start to really get up
the evidence gets richer and richer and
richer so I just I'd like to see the
fabric kind of more evenly woven you
know one thing that you don't see so
much is long shots and the power of the
long shot of the sort of endless trip of
Market Street or the long shot of people
just streaming by and their amazing
plumage going to a game and just goes
and it goes and goes and you disappear
into your viewing of it because of that
persistence I think yeah I feel like the
everyday is
is what needs to be captured in ways
that it isn't work is not something that
that's captured very well at least not
by people who are doing the work and and
that that experience of being on the
street and watching people pass you is
is definitely an everyday thing that we
don't we don't have access to in a lot
of ways except if you film it I used to
collect photographs of buildings over
time there's certain parts of buildings
that are never photographed the bathroom
which is interesting is a lot of stuff
going on in it off in the kitchen you
know the the action is out on the porch
or in the parlor what's going on in the
bedroom what's going on in the attic
what's going on in the basement what's
going on in the backyard not just the
front yard the places where nobody turns
on the camera turn on a camera ya know
what what you said in what Suzanne said
if you work in a cube what's life like
in a cube but people are gonna wonder
and you know they won't want to have to
rely just on a Douglas Coupland novel to
understand what it's like to be a cube
rat 50 years hence so um you know as
they say everyone her own historian this
is a shared responsibility we can't
leave this up to professional
documentaries and of course we can't
leave it up to professional archivists
either the job is just too big so we we
need to record and we need to preserve
as part of our or daily life so back up
your your Adam videos I think that's the
message for tonight yeah and then and
then there are parts of San Francisco
that have completely disappeared I would
love to see footage of the old produce
market which is oh yeah where the Golden
Gate do yeah and things like the the Fox
Theater for example there's I hear that
there's footage of the demolition of the
Fox and also the rebuilding and the
Palace of Fine Arts and when the palace
was like before they rebuilt it when it
was that I was still wonderful crazy
ruined
and Sutro Baths of course - and the Old
Palace of Fine Arts was just the stucco
and basically two by fours and I snuck
in there one time what crawled all over
it and photograph the decaying stucco
was fabulous
should we call it a night it's a night
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you